It is the failure of the Euro, threatening to bring
down the continent and the rest of the world.
How did it happen?
What’s happening? Failing currencies?
Collapsing banks.
Whole countries on the edge of bankruptcy?
- The upside versus the downside
in Greece is pretty attractive.
- A stressed investor who
truly understands great value.
But the investors fill their pockets anyway.
Have we lost control of the economy?
My name’s Amund.
I’ve always been fascinated by economics.
How it affects society;
How it affects you and me.
Is there an invisible hand
pulling the strings?
Or is it self-governing, based on principles
we neither understand nor control?
How can we regain control?
That’s what I’ve been wondering about.
That was how I discovered Bitcoin.
Bitcoin is a decentralised payment system.
The first specially-made internet currency.
100s of 1000s of computers around the world
work equally in a network...
...to create, move and record ownership
of the digital units known as Bitcoins.
Bitcoins are programmable digital cash.
You can send however much you want to
whoever you want, wherever you want...
...almost free of charge
and completely anonymously.
Do we really need a new currency?
A revolution? Fine!
But is it good or bad?
Since 2009, the value of the bitcoin
has varied by several million per cent.
The currency has been linked with
criminal networks and shady business.
Neither the Norwegian authorities nor others
welcome the revolution.
Despite the warnings, bitcoin has gone from
obscure programme to billion industry.
Many people have embraced the technology.
what makes it so attractive?
I’ve had one bitcoin and it does work.
Satoshi Nakamoto...
It’s a name I’m going to hear many times.
That’s when I decided.
I had to see how bitcoin actually works.
My itinerary’s ready. My digital wallet full.
I’m off!
Is Scandinavia ready for Bitcoin?
Day one. Forget Bitcoin.
Cash is King.
What’s needed for garages
and other shops to accept Bitcoin?
Could the answer lie in an office block outside Copenhagen?
- What is Coinify?
- It’s a means of payment for
companies wanting to take Bitcoin.
We have all sorts: Food, clothes,
internet services, electro etc.
We’re the bridge between the old
financial world and Bitcoin.
- A customer want to buy something
from a shop with Bitcoin.
Bitcoin goes via Coinify who returns
it to the shop in Euros or Kroner..
There are a number of advantages.
The shop keeps accounts as usual...
...they pay no fees to accept
payments from Bitcoin...
...there are no chargeback frauds
as with credit cards...
...and it’s a one-click payment,
so it’s easy.
- Do you feel that Coinify
is supported by the Danish authorities?
- Three years ago, laws about Bitcoin
were uncertain in Denmark and Europe.
Now it’s better. We know the legal
position for Bitcoin in most areas.
It can still get better,
but it is pretty good.
- The Danish authorities are positive.
What about the rest of Scandinavia?
- Finland yes, Sweden iffy, Norway no.
- What makes it so difficult
to regulate Bitcoin?
The question brought me here.
The Copenhagen docklands.
Can Bitcoin and the financial world
live in harmony together?
Will Scandinavian countries give
Bitcoin and digital currencies a chance?
I think I’m ready for a beer!
- What do you think
will be the future of Bitcoin?
- Maybe I should talk a bit
about the past?
When Bitcoin came out in 2008-9,
it seemed crazy.
I was interested because the core of Bitcoin
is a code which I wanted to try to break.
Many have tried but none succeeded.
So Bitcoin could be here to stay.
- What about Bitcoin and society?
Is it good news or bad news?
- You can control all your money;
You don’t need a 3rd party or bank.
- The only way to get out of the boot
of government is to build a system...
...a currency that works completely
outside centralised control.
And that is what we have today.
It’s dissemination of power.
A paradigm shift.
Gothenburg.
Home to Volvo, Ullevi, Liseberg.
And Bitcoin pioneers.
The usual suspects.
The traffic dept. still has some way to go.
How many have taken the leap?
How big is Bitcoin really?
Currently there are about 100,000
Bitcoin transactions per day.
In comparison, Visa alone has
4,000 transactions per second.
Can Bitcoin challenge the banks’ monopoly?
Will the system work on a large scale?
Then there must be more places like Webhallen:
The first big chain store to take Bitcoin.
Every day 200,000 Bitcoins change hands.
Only 2.5% is used in shops.
That’s around 1.2 million US dollars.
A drop in the ocean against USD 60 billion
in retail trade every day.
You have to start somewhere.
The block chain. A system for transactions
with no central authority.
Buying and selling, work contracts,
voting slips – everything can be stored here.
With no bureaucracy or state control.
That’ll be a challenge to society.
Maybe on a deeper level
than we might suppose.
A Ugandan Bitcoin trader explains why
East Africa is ready for Bitcoin.
- We don’t have PayPal or credit cards
like other countries.
We use mobile phone transfers.
It is a little bit like Bitcoin.
In the future all of us will use Bitcoin.
- It’s about democracy.
Can Bitcoin democratise society?
Many people think so.
The Swedish Bitcoin Party for example.
We’re to meet outside the Riksdag.
Freedom is built into the block chain
where all Bitcoin transactions are recorded.
Single transactions are collected in blocks
which the network registers every 10 mins.
The blocks form a chain all the way back
to the first signed by Nakamoto in 2009.
There’s something religious about it.
Maybe that’s why I’m here in Sollentuna,
outside Stockholm. Looking for...
- Roberth!
- Hi!
A democratising technology; a shared
value system; a people’s currency.
Bitcoin must be good, mustn’t it?
But banking and finance are resisting.
Are they scared of losing control?
Or are they seeing something I’m not?
Boden, Nordbotten.
80km south of the Arctic Circle.
Is it here I will find the answers?
I’m going into an old helicopter hangar.
And I think I know what’s hiding there.
It’s here I’m hoping to find
the heart of Bitcoin.
- Welcome to KNC Clear Sky Farm.
Physically I can’t get any closer to Bitcoin.
In this hall alone, there are
43,000 specialised computers.
It’s here the value of Bitcoin lies.
This is where the block chain is created.
What is the motivation?
- Who is behind it?
- You better talk to Sam.
- What is Bitcoin mining?
- Bitcoin mining is transaction processing.
- If someone wants to send a Bitcoin
from A to B it must be guaranteed.
We don’t want person A to be able
to use the same Bitcoin twice.
So you must be able to trust the network
which guarantees the money is real...
...that the Bitcoin won’t be sent elsewhere
and the transaction will be confirmed.
The miners create blocks of transactions
and have a mathematical problem to solve.
When they solve the problem,
they announce to the network:
”“I have solved it and included all these
transactions in my block.”
So Bitcoin mining is really
transaction confirmation.
- How are new Bitcoins put into circulation?
- As soon as you have created a new block
full of transactions, you get 25 new Bitcoins.
And you get to decide where they go.
We send then to ourselves first,
then to our customers.
- So that is the motivation for
creating this centre?
- Imagine 3,600 new coins per day; the more
computer power you have, the more you get.
If you only have one computer
you don’t stand a chance.
So you have this hypergrowth
of this Bitcoin network.
- How secure is the network?
- The more computer power in the chain,
the more secure the chain is.
If you want to take a transaction out,
you would need 4 billion laptops...
...and you would have approximately
10 minutes to do it.
- How many laptops do you have
in your facility?
- Laptops don’t work for us.
We have very specialised chips.
The technology we use is cutting edge.
It is beyond mobile phones.
It is the bleeding edge
of the semi-conductor industry.
Bitcoin is the world’s most secure network .
Nobody has greater computer power than us.
The world’s most secure network?
Can that be correct?
So Bitcoin is safer than the bank.
In terms of computer power, it’s the
world’s fastest growing payment network.
How come such cutting edge technology
has wound up in the Swedish countryside?
Is that to be the conclusion from
this experiment?
2,500 km for a cake and a ‘Sorry, no’?
No!
Maybe Scandinavia’s not ready for Bitcoin.
It’s not easy to hand power and control
to technology from an unknown source.
But one thing is for sure:
We have got a technology that will
revolutionise how we act together.
It is up to us to use it.
To democratise the economy
and thus create a better society.
That way we can all be Satoshi Nakamoto.